Luke and Tom here with the outdoor boys
YouTube channel and we're going to show
you how to make Lucille yep for all you
Walking Dead fans out here here's
Nagin's bat Lucille and it is savage man
this thing just feel dirty in the hand
it's it's bad and me and Tommy are going
to be making a little zombie movie here
in a week or so for my other YouTube
channel to catfish and carp YouTube
channel - zombie apocalypse fishing
video it'll make sense don't worry so I
wanted a little prop for it and so I'm
making making this bat and this thing is
legit so we're going to show you how to
make it and then we're going to smash a
bunch of crap we're going to do some
brutal pinatas on this any rate check it
out so I've got everything here do I
need to do this I've got some barbed
wire is the real legit barbed wire I've
got a Louie's Pflugerville a la softball
bat and I got the longest one I could
because most bats nowadays come with
this concave bit in the end and the bat
in the movie does not have it throughout
it old school and so what I'm going to
do is I want to chop off that concave
bit so I need one a little bit extra
length and I believe this is like a 32
inch or or and anyways this is a nice
solid ash bat and I'm going to stand it
I've got some red mahogany wood stain
hopefully won't be too dark it is I can
tone it down with the linseed oil or
something and I've got some paint and
varnish stripper here so I'm going to
take off all this lacquer here and then
I've got to stand out all the little
logos and everything then chop off the
edge andrey round it then stain it and
then wrap it with barbed wire and that
should make a pretty sick looking
Lucille then of course you've gotta test
it out and see if it's as cool as it is
on the show see if we can't smash the
schools with this in so I've got all the
tools and everything I think I need to
do this and we're gonna see what happens
I actually take the lettering off Mel
because you're dumb again
yeah I am Not sure that paint everything
good
nothin purple man look at this this
looks great I mean that varnish came off
the acetone dried really quick the
lettering is all gone
you can just see slight indentations
where the lettering used to be it's
going to take very little sanding to get
rid of all that and all I've got to do
now is cut a little bit of the end off
to get rid of the concave bit so I can
have it in bevel that's pretty even
[Music]
well this is looking pretty good I'm
liking this not the ends looking nice
and rounded the color is good it's a
little more reddish brown than I would
have prefered I think actions are much
more of a yellowish brown but it still
looks really nice it's a pretty close
match now I'm going to rub it down with
some linseed oil and they were going to
put some barbed wire on it
[Music]
this is a lot more work than I imagined
my forearms are absolutely wasted right
now I'm twisting this thing and holding
it tight so it doesn't uncoil on you is
a chore if I this is really a two-man
job
one guy twist and hold until I nail in
it but hey make do with what you got so
we'll keep going we're almost done my
goodness this thing is brutal it feels
so much more savage in the hands that
looks on phil this thing is incredible
you know it's got a lot of extra weight
to it I mean in having that it's got
about 12 15 feet of barbed wire wrapped
around and this adds a lot of weight to
this this thing is man it is savage look
at it see is definitely a vampire bat
those galvanized nails just disappeared
in the barbed wire you can't hardly tell
I use them they're the same diameter is
the wire same kind of galvanization as
the wire just blends right in
she absolutely need them the whole thing
would come unraveled in a heartbeat if
you didn't have it give it away you're
my good
[Applause]
we're gonna oh look at that I'm like Ted
Nugent after down there ready step super
now go for it got a piece going down
there okay they never did it lesson well
thanks for watching I hope you liked
this video I hope you learned a little
something had some fun if you like to
see more videos like this click
Subscribe we put out new videos all the
time
[Music]